welcome to the weekly poll I'm
spider-man welcoming you to the weekly
poll with comic story and a barbell
explained in comics reviews now I'm
gonna go cry about losing Mary Jane what
is that behind him that venom I don't
know or or Rob cashews the intro welcome
to the week people I'm Batman and
somehow magically was able to defeat
Nick Fury yeah awesome nobody I guess I
can debate better nobody knows how he
could beat Nick Fury but he was able to
so welcome to the weekly poll this is
our podcast that we run every week um as
usual if you want to see our vs. debate
it happens over in comic story and
before this this week was Mixel pillock
vs. mad Jim Jasper's or as Rob was
saying fish sticks versus nanotubes
aspirants good luck that pronounce that
name I'm alright so um so for this
podcast we actually don't really have
any major topics I've been shining Vinny
and Dave no glass no Robert Downey jr.
is leaving Marvel my people think that's
what's going on yeah that's all we lost
we lost to him again I can't come
anymore intros for just spider-man 1
against Kurt's Dave you're killing that
wasn't me this time your voice you
disconnected regardless of it being your
fault or not yeah dude you froze up man
well my internet was fine the other
majority rules man yeah history of us
here ative two of us or stayed in the
call then you lose like all of like
everybody watching this video is gonna
be like yeah Dave is your fault yeah if
you agree with us in the comments down
below just Dave it's your fault just say
thanks a lot Dave comment just leave
that comment yeah anybody who just
watched our vs. match is aware of the
fact that Rob claims that Robert Downey
jr. is leaving Marvel mm-hmm and I've
been shining everybody on and that's not
happening
I felt like screwing with people as far
as I know to the best of my knowledge
Robert Downey jr. is not leaving Marvel
Studios it's not and and you know it's
gonna be funny you're saying that now
but like as soon as this goes live
they're going to announce it do it we're
gonna be wrong twice we're gonna be
wrong but that kind of lets us segue
into to our topping because for the most
part we're just kind of shooting from
the hip you know for the last couple
episodes we've had kind of like this
somewhat regimented you know like
discussion like we want to talk about
like these three things
now we sidetrack like crazy and it never
usually works out that way so we figured
you know we're just gonna kind of shoot
from the hip and how to talk about what
seems interesting at the moment I know
biddings going to talk about some weekly
comics and whether or not they're worth
you know buying whether or not it's a
good idea to really invest in that and I
actually want to talk about Robert
Downey jr. as Iron Man because we've
kind of like skirted around that like
we've kind of talked about it a little
bit but haven't gotten into like a real
discussion of like is he really good as
Iron Man like is he really like a good
Tony Stark and I do want to say we're
not going away from the topic style of
the podcast but there isn't always big
topics every weekend comic news so we
need to have some just general
discussions too and that's what this
week is all all about yeah definitely so
alright so 20 stars Robert Downey jr. so
amazing move on we've talked about this
Tony Stark in the comics is not this
interesting an infinity he was
interesting cuz he was a bad guy I
wanted him like I didn't touch him that
on my story but he's the one that's like
doc no we don't care about you losing
your families we have to go stop this
other issue everyone stopped giving a
[ __ ] oh I know like oh yeah we just lost
a lane test Tony he's like oh yeah how'd
that work out for you Namor it's gone
are we gonna go yeah and the name were
launched the strike against against like
everybody else on earth so yeah I mean I
like Robert Downey jr. as a character
and here's here's my question this is
probably the biggest question that I
have regarding Robert Downey jr. and and
Marvel are they going to touch on xx
Starks alcoholism because I'm not that
like Robert Downey jr. has some past
demons they were supposed to that well a
lot of when it got glanced
because they were going because Disney
had bought out they were going for more
family-friendly appearance oh yes that
that was the plot the second movie
Avengers 2
if Iron Man's own creation turns on him
that could be a trigger no no I was
actually reading about this um the the
alcoholism thing was supposed to be the
plot for the second one but it was also
later Roza with another interesting
picture really it's fine you putting
your finger in it like you're hinting at
every one of our viewers hey guys
subscribe that's exactly where it froze
oh maybe it didn't freeze
no no he's Moody and it's in freeze
you're not crazy it wasn't you were just
sitting perfectly still Dave yes I was
broke down and you're delayed yeah your
internet is horrible today doing that is
terrible yeah what are you doing then I
have waited too long well what's going
on anyway while we're waiting for Dave
while we're waiting for Dave to rejoin
us from the land of Alaska yeah I have
no idea where Dave I think he's like in
Michigan or something like that but I
mean Dave will take your silence as a
man I failed today yeah see he agrees
all right so so before Dave disappeared
off the face of the earth and he brought
up a pretty interesting point so if it
does turn out that Ultron is a creation
of Tony Stark in Avengers 2 it may be
either that kind of triggers is
alcoholism because his alcoholism was
like a big part of Tony Stark's
character in the Marvel comics like he
was always battling alcoholism right now
but it's like I was saying um he that
was the plot of Iron Man 2 that also
happened during the Disney buyout and
they adapt it to be more family-friendly
so his alcoholism got briefly touched on
and it got dummy down to almost almost
non-existent that's why you don't even
realize it but the whole scene where he
was getting drunk and with his armor on
in the middle of
that was a part supposed to be a part of
the whole demon in a bottle plotline
yeah so they do what they've already
kind of touched on it in a matter of
fact that if you notice in Avengers in
an Iron Man 3 he avoids alcohol as if it
was a major problem like in demon in the
bottle it so they basically are
acknowledging it happen but we're not
gonna really touch on see I'll rather
they touch on that because it made his
character like really dynamic
it made him resting I mean I would have
rather had that entire movie be about a
superhero becomes an alcoholic like
would that that's a great concept to
begin with that's one of the things that
started making Tony Stark Tony Stark
let's see here's one of the cool things
to that I was I was thinking about when
it came to Robert Downey jr. playing
Tony Stark do you see cuz I know you've
read the storyline do you see Robert
Downey jr. as Tony Stark is like the
Civil War Tony Stark yeah I could see
that see for me it's kind of hard to
connect it to you I could I mean he's
never seen us
the problem is in his books he's never
serious in his books he's Tony Stark
from the Avengers yeah everything else
he's evil leader of the Illuminati yeah
exactly like the New Avengers he's a
founder of the Illuminati yeah so it's
almost like we have two versions of Iron
Man being played off because they're
trying to cater to the people who like
the movies but at the same time Bendis
already had a plan for what he was gonna
do with Iron Man yeah and I would like
to have seen that come to fruition I
would have liked us because Michael I'm
a man Bendis can ride like some
seriously good books like I you know
going through like the Civil War
storyline so I kind of like he can he
can write I mean Brian Michael Bendis
can can do some amazing storytelling so
I would like to have seen where he could
go with Tony Stark and just how deep of
a character he could take him but you
know I the one thing that I'm worried
about because I didn't realize that they
were supposed to like include the
alcoholism of Tony Stark
but I've read a lot of things recently
about that one and I remember reading
originally when they wrote Iron Man 2
that that was what it was it was the
demon in the bottle see I wish they'd
kept that because you know I understand
the Disney owns it and NZ doesn't
necessarily want to kind of have their
name tied to the darker elements
you know the way that comics can get but
you know when it comes to a character
like Iron Man when it comes to a lot of
the characters of Marvel Comics what
makes them unique is the fact that
they're they're down like they're
they're gritty like they're they're you
and me and they have problems and they
struggle I mean you see that writing
Civil War like there were superheroes
who just stopped being superheroes
because they just can't afford to be
superheroes anymore cuz they have day
jobs and they don't want to lose their
jobs you know or they're in college and
they don't want to be you know kicked
out of college I mean there's all kinds
of different things going on but you
know with Tony Stark having like
battling alcoholism I thought was a
really cool element to his character and
you know this is the kind of thing I was
afraid of when we learned that Disney
was gonna be taking over Marvel is that
we'd see this exact kind of thing where
we see like this kind of toning down of
elements of the comic book where we see
this kind of like you know ramping up of
family-friendly themes and stuff like
that which is cool oh it is cool but
it's kind of a problem you look at the
Avengers half of the Avengers movie is
all just funny jokes and how can we get
along yeah it's a great movie I loved it
but that's what it is look at Thor 2
Thor 2 is about is the darkest Thor
we've had and even that was more of a
jokey oh look at the guy who just got
powers lift a car oh look at the hammer
go flying oh look at Jane make a joke
you know it was the family-friendly
action movie that's true but also look
at Captain America the Winter Soldier
that was how many how much swearing was
there how much death was there how much
darker tone elements was there not very
much it was like a superhero action
movie kind of toned down for kids a
little man I mean there's a lot of
destruction but it was pg-13 destruction
that's pigs explode no one dies people
survive massive things like jumping out
of an air carrier I loved the movie
don't get me wrong guys I'm not bashing
on the movie but what I'm stating is it
is more toned-down for the Disney
audience it really is they they're
trying to I mean if you look at it
Disney's now promoting Avengers Disney
infinity they've got games coming out
for the Avengers Disney XD has got an
Avengers TV show and they're trying to
make as even with this subset continuity
somebody can watch the Disney of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes and then go watch the
movie well but here's the thing I mean
the great thing about the Captain
America the Winter Soldier film is that
for me it follow a lot of elements of
the comics in the sense that you don't
have to have all kinds of swearing and
like gratuitous violence to have a good
story you know or to be able to have
like a good movie
like I thought Captain America the
Winter Soldier was it was great for what
it was like you had political themes you
had you know this is fear and freedom
and all I kind of suddenly had all those
kind of themes that were going on you
know they were they were they were great
themes and it was a great story but you
know at the end of the day he'll take ok
I mean let me ask you this Winter
Soldier
would you take a 6 year old 6 year old
kid to go see that that's how you should
look at it because that's probably how
Disney looks at it well all right which
would explain why demon and about it was
toned down because no one's gonna take a
six-year-old kid to see Iron Man get
drunk that's true but even then I
wouldn't take a kid to see Catholic ok
all right ok let's think about this from
the perspective of people that are not
us like we're knowledgeable about comics
we've read a lot of this stuff we know
about the Ed Brubaker run of the Winter
Soldier so let's say that we don't know
anything about comic books alright and
with all the movies that I've been
released to date then your question
being asked would I take a six-year-old
to see Captain America the Winter
Soldier yes exactly because is a Captain
America movie I mean it's right on
Captain America one of the movies have
you seen so far okay yes it is a
family-friendly kid-friendly kind of
thing I mean look at the Winter Soldier
is crazy assassin who's done a lot of
dirty things and in that movie
other than implying he did it he didn't
do anything yeah well see that was one
of the things that I that I was really
disappointed on them disappointed with
him doing alright
the coolest thing about the Ed Brubaker
run the Stanley Jack Kirby you know kind
of Captain America from the 1960s and
even the Captain America from the 1940s
basically they kind of established Bucky
Barnes is like the family-friendly
sidekick he was like the Robin of
Captain America all right Dave literally
was I think I think he was literally
made to be yeah yeah I mean that's this
I mean that was kind of that was the
one-two punch back in the day like
Marvel you had Bucky Barnes and Captain
America that was the Batman and Robin of
Marvel and DC around the verbal
connection and of course you had Batman
and Robin and the the most popular
sidekick superhero duo of all time but
um when Ed McGuinness I'm sorry Ed
Brubaker came around he said that the
whole idea of Bucky Barnes was to be a
darker character that Bucky Barnes was
designed to be the sidekick of Captain
America because he was willing to do the
things that Captain America wasn't
willing to do like half the merica was
not willing to kill people but Bucky
Barnes would yeah well no what they did
was they reinvented Bucky Barnes because
Bucky Barnes was kid friendly and the
reinvention was he was a top secret
assassin so it made sense for him to
become the Winter Soldier
yeah and that's that's one of the things
I liked about Ed about Ed Brubaker thing
because it took it it brought Bucky
Barnes into a real world and so like the
modern-day Marvel Comics because you
know if someone like Bucky Barnes was
introduced in monitor comics as being
like a 1960s character nobody would take
him seriously they think he was silly
and they'd be lucky this is kind of a
stupid character well just like Robin
even Robin Eddie even in just that
outfit you can't run around in like
underwear shoes that's true that's true
but um but nonetheless like you know the
one thing on a sidenote did you see that
video 1960s Robin teams up with Dark
Knight from Dark Knight Rises huh oh my
god it's hilarious it's it's like Bane
and Batman fighting it out he just got
music all right holy smokes look at the
reason I bring that up real quick is
because it's exactly what you're talking
about you can't take those print
family-friendly kit sidekicks and put
them into nowadays nowadays Batman is
dark and gritty and evil and you get a
chippy Burt Ward in 1960s Robin who's
jumping around and all happy-go-lucky
and everything's gonna work out in the
end doesn't work yeah and that's why
Bucky had to get reinvented but see
here's the thing like in the in the
films we didn't see that like in the
movies we didn't see the Bucky Barnes
reinvention the Ed Brubaker Bucky Barnes
and that's what I really liked about
Bucky Barnes because what I went through
and do it I said actually Bucky got his
own reinvention in the entire show and
the movie I mean he was older than Kevin
American he helps get him in yeah
totally different character yeah totally
different but nonetheless like I like
the element
of you know I'd like what they did with
Captain America one it wasn't a bad
movie like it's it's it's one of my top
three Marvel films and they've come out
with so far but to me Bucky Barnes was
for the most part the opposite of
Captain America and that was what he was
designed to be by Ed Brubaker he was
yeah I mean we saw that in the a
Brubaker one at Brubaker run when they
gave us one the backstory the origin
story of Bucky Barnes the way that Ed
Brubaker had done it and to when we
actually saw you know Captain America
vol 5 and we actually saw the run of Ed
Brubaker when he first you know when he
first took over the Captain America helm
for me it was this Bucky Barnes who was
going in and assassinating people he was
killing people you know he was he was
committing some pretty heinous acts
because that's what he was trained to do
he was trained by the government to be
the sidekick of Captain America and to
go in and do some really shady stuff he
had a really bad past you know he had a
violent past oh okay I've reset
everything the phone the router the
switch yoga hopefully it stays if not I
guess by disconnect you guys just keep
going well that's what we did like we
were talking about actually before you
joined up like the whole Marvel Comics
and this is my distaste for Dave's
recent connection okay so so me and
Vinny were talking about the Marvel
films and how they're like
family-friendly films for the most part
and he brings a really good point he
said would you take a six-year-old to
see Captain America and we're Captain
America the Winter Soldier and I told
him that if you know looking at it from
a non Marvel Comics readers perspective
from a soccer mom or somebody that just
doesn't know anything about comics all
the other comic books comic book movies
we'd seen up to that point my answer
would be yes because you would think
that it would be family-friendly now
there were elements of it that were that
were you know kind of dark and more
serious but for the most part I kind of
thought it with Danny on that one well
right here's what I was thinking real
quick about that wrote real fast before
you jump in Dave um what I like what
they're doing with it because what
they've done now is demon in the bottle
was implied in pretty much it was stated
almost that
happen during Iron Man 2 we got just
enough the that comic-book fans were
like Oh
demons bottles going on he's getting
drunk but they pulled back enough that
you could still bring his six year old
to see that movie and in Winter Soldier
when her soldier didn't actually kill
anybody or do anything insane like like
oh my god evil assassination kind of
stuff but we heard all about it how he's
been around for years and all this stuff
so comic book fans like Oh Winter
Soldier crazy assassin but when you look
at the video V as a hold you can still
take a sick show to go see it because
the Winter Soldier didn't do any of that
Yeah right and so they're trying to
cater to us the fans but keep it online
with they're aiming for a PG pg-13
rating on all this stuff mm-hmm
they're trying to make it for the
largest broadest audience they can do
which you know to degree that makes
sense I mean you know it was like World
War Z for example a kind of side track
like people were up in arms about World
War Z about how the movie was nothing
like the book and so on and so forth but
when you've got a production company
that's coming in and they're making a
movie they've got to make it for as many
people as possible and I'm not that many
people that read World War Z what War Z
was kind of like a cool book I mean
there were a lot of people that did but
it was a very small niche of society and
when you're talking about something as
popular as zombies they have to do it in
a way where people that don't know
anything about World War Z don't know
what it's based on and don't know
anything about the Max Brooks novel
we'll go and see the movie and so what
these are is it's the exact same way but
what I'm still in bidding was one of the
things I didn't like was with the
original Captain America film Captain
America the First Avenger Bucky Barnes
was not revamped he was not the way that
he was in the comics and well I wouldn't
necessarily go as far as to say that I'm
like a huge stickler that they have to
match the comic book characters I'm not
really like that anymore what I would
say is that the way that Ed Brubaker did
Bucky Barnes when mine went like first
way he did Bucky Barnes was he made in a
much darker character he made him the
guy that would do stuff that Captain
America wasn't willing to do but you
know Bucky Barnes would kill people he
would infiltrate he was good at
espionage he was good at all that kind
of stuff he was a very skilled assassin
and spy and those skills carried over
when he became the Winter Soldier and so
now like you know when Captain America
the Winter Soldier came out we didn't
really know the back story of Bucky
Barnes until almost
you know three quarters of the way to
the movie and then we thought he was saw
that he was brainwashed but what we
didn't get was the fact that all these
skills that he had over the years that
he had utilized traveling with Captain
America fighting in World War two with
Captain America assassinating and
breaking into secret government bases in
Europe with Captain America
those were skills that helped him to
develop and to become you know Bucky
Barnes the Winter Soldier during the Ed
Brubaker run of Captain America and so I
really would have loved to have seen
that element of Bucky Barnes character I
really would have loved to have seen the
violin and the you know sadistic more or
less kind of Bucky Barnes because it
means character interesting you know
during the the volume five Ed Brubaker
run of Captain America and it would have
made his character a little more
relatable in a film well yeah I guess in
in the cinematic universe if if that's
the case they kind of killed him off too
early so to speak because they saw the
friendship between Captain America and
Bucky builds you know over their lives
at home and you know their their lives
while they were fighting together but we
didn't really see any of you know him
doing it much different he was just
helping Captain America right well I
mean this actually goes back to that
discussion where it goes back to what we
talked about last week where did not go
to adapt for the comics they are trying
to hit the largest target audience
that's the whole entire purpose of these
movies x-men changing Days of Future
past because everyone wants to Vereen
not Kitty Pryde and making Bucky Barnes
the family-friendly assassin which is
pretty much what they've done yeah is to
target the largest audience assassins
are cool and you know parents will be
like you don't do what you want to go
blast in the past GI Joe what snake eyes
not everybody's favorite GI Joe make a
bad storm shadow with a - cool did they
ever assassinate anyone you knew what
they were they were ninja assassin that
was what they did they infiltrated they
did cool stuff but did they ever
actually do it no in the cartoon show
they they just fought and that was it
because there because the implication or
just the
that they'll do it is enough well that's
what it comes down to but see that
that's why the Ed Brubaker run of
Captain America was so important that's
why him revamping Bucky Barnes and
bringing him back was so important
because you know with the original
Captain America comics there were
sidekicks and they were a reflection of
society at the time so you didn't have
extreme violence with those characters
you know with the Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby run of Captain America you didn't
really see anything about Bucky Bombers
he appeared to some backstories but
there was no character development
because he at the he had been assumed to
be dead and so there was no reason to
really do any character development so
he appeared sporadically
over the course of the Avengers and
Captain America comics and it was do you
know there wasn't anything major there
and then Ed Brubaker cracks along and Ed
Brubaker says here's the entire
backstory of Bucky Barnes and here's how
he really was and everything that you
read and the original Captain America
comics was kind of a sham and it wasn't
that's not really what was going on
that's why it was so serious because it
gave us the backstory of Bucky Barnes
and so we were basically getting like a
new character but more or less kind of
being reintroduced to a character that
we had already known already known about
before and so that's why it was so big
and that's why it was so interesting and
that's why I would have liked to have
seen him portrayed that way because for
the most part there's really no
backstory when it comes to Bucky Barnes
aside from the Ed Brubaker run but that
doesn't really need to be I mean in the
1960s there's no backstory really did
anybody write I mean know everyone gets
an origin story and that was it we
didn't develop characters the 1960s
Batman wasn't developed Superman wasn't
developed you know Superman was a guy
that that crash land on earth is an
alien trying to get along and now he's
gonna stop a bank robber
you know the Captain America was a super
soldier for the US government just stop
cut Nazis and that was it that was the
tag line back again you know like that's
true that's true but I mean you look at
other classic heroes so that way they
brought out back in the day even the
x-men you know they're trying even
that's even more current but they were
only introduced to show basically you
know segregation in society the x-men
show students learning under Charles
Xavier and now they're going to stop a
bank robber
I don't think robbers are a big thing
that was the biggest threat got a thing
in the 1960s how violent could you
really be in coloring books I mean like
needs of future passes play well that
was even the 1960s that was a tease so
you can remember even back then like you
know I guess I guess it was more in the
70s in the 80s but I heard about you
know people like ranting about comics
destroying like childhoods and right
right rage Rob this is why they did not
elaborate on a lot of this stuff where
if your music was had too many guitar
riffs you were considered satanic yeah I
just got done watching a movie about the
Memphis Three they got the guys who
listen to music and like to wicken who
got accused of the deaths of three kids
in the late 90s Wow
and all because they listen to music and
read Wiccan books and they've just
gotten acquitted in and sent off like
like it is only recent that people have
really started to accept darker kind of
tones of stuff even in the 90s it really
wasn't but look look at comic books in
the 90s everything was just flash in the
pan stuff bright colors crazy stuff
going on and your darkest character
spawn yeah all these characters in my
head like I'm thinking evil do believe
room rate was just dark and moody yeah
yeah so I mean basically what they've
done with the comic books is they've
just kind of gone back to the way things
were but they are given us the current
comic fans what we want when it comes to
iron man and demon in the bottle I'm
gonna keep pulling it back to the topic
Rob because it's even in the bottle and
book eat Bucky and the Winter Soldier
they're going back to the comic books
that kids will read you know kids aren't
mom is not gonna let little Davey of 12
years old man that beard is crazy for 12
year old little Davey go get a Winter
Soldier comic and watch him assassinate
a bunch of people the but she will let
him get a comic where it's implied that
it happened that yes he is a darker guy
but he always moves for the greater good
yeah but yeah you don't actually see its
headlines right now this Superman will
kill somebody you know how often do you
hear about somebody whenever somebody
dies in a comic and it's a bloody
fashion it always makes headlines oh my
god even like you know when when they
came out and said Batman you know
doesn't kill people and that's his moral
code but think about how many people
he's thrown off a roof or let fall off a
roof it's always off to the side you
never really see you know I'll give you
one more though he doesn't actually kill
people but think about the amount of
stuff he does to people and how many
people that would have killed if this
wasn't a comic book right or or the
stuff he just lets happen I mean I know
they're bad people but you know if they
lose their balance and stumble off the
roof it's not like he chases them you
know it's not like he's lying down in a
save the building actually he dies but
there are other versions of Batman they
come out with like Thomas Wayne that
just throws people off the building yeah
thanks Pam buh-bye
but Thomas Wayne were supposed to be
like an alternate reality version of the
two bad names really the only one that
won't kill still but they pretty much
allowed everyone else to do that so if
you read if you read if you saw my
forever evil video I got a bunch of
comments people go WOW DC how violent
they were stepping on people they were
cutting off limbs on people they were
killing people outright shoving spears
in their chest like and as much as
people like the story it got reviewed as
this is violent don't let your kids read
this well that's one of the reasons my
Deadpool was really controversial see
Deadpool yeah when they when they
brought him in and he had his healing
factor it was it was it was kind of a
big deal because like he would like
people would throw grenades at him and
like it would blow holes in his body
yeah yeah Civil War like he's going
against the Great Lakes Avengers and he
pulls a grenade and blows a hole in his
stomach you know in order to just you
know to kind of defeat the Great Lakes
Avengers and then he just heals himself
but a lot of kids yeah a lot of kids
weren't able to differentiate between
this exam again yeah we're losing David
oh no no we're not no no
sit down as soon as that goes down I
want everyone to go to comments to be
like damn you Dave this is a log without
me but we just want to see damn you Dave
over and over and over
fierce man man Dave will remember you
will hold on to building a same day
because he's falling oh I'm gonna get a
new modem tonight okay it's happening
word and now your mouth is saying what
you just said really cool maybe it's
something that's going on with Comcast
and by modem there you go now you're
caught back up again is he yeah it
looked like it yeah but but anyway so so
the whole thing with with them Deadpool
was it it established this idea that
kids could do anything
you know kids didn't understand the idea
of ramifications that's why it was a big
deal because no matter what Deadpool did
he always healed he always came back and
so I did do it so Hoover reading but
Wolverine didn't do it in a comical
sense yeah he didn't make he didn't he
didn't make it like an enjoyment thing
like this is fun to destroy myself to
destroy the enemy kind of thing all
right like Deadpool had no real regard
for life like he was dark and he's
really he was really screwed up and he'd
do oh you know he'd killed a Deadpool
Deadpool vs carnage he did that to kill
carnage yeah yeah but we kill ourselves
yeah like a lot of kids you know when
you're young you don't understand the
ramifications of your actions just part
of being young you still know how that's
work
and so a lot of kids would look at
Deadpool and they would say that's funny
and then they would do stupid stuff this
was a big thing you know back in the in
the late 90s you know a lot of parents
are freaking out over that you know and
so you know I understand the idea that
not every character who's represented in
a comic books can be represented that
way on the silver screen and I
understand I mean that's that's fine
with me you know but there are some
characters that you just can't deviate
from because you know the character is
represented to us at some point in the
comic is the most memorable form of that
character like nobody remembers Bucky
but or not nobody really cares about
Bucky Barnes back in the 1940s with
Captain America but when you say Bucky
Barnes people think of Winter Soldier
right so you know that's the Bucky
Barnes and everybody knows and everybody
loves the Bucky Barnes I took over for
Captain America when he was assassinated
by Sharon Carter I mean you know it was
it was a really really kind of cool
event that took place you know with this
character and its evolution in Marvel
Comics and so you know to really kind of
skim over a lot of that and to say well
he was a friend of Captain America as
any fell off a train and now all the
sudden he's one of the so you know the
Winter Soldier people just kind of like
alright what's you know what's going on
here you know I mean they touched on
he's a good friend and they touched on
the train thing and they touched on
everything and then when we got to the
Winter Soldier they're just like oh yeah
he's this amazing assassin killed
countless people and that's pretty much
all they said everyone be afraid of him
he's a crazy assassin so us comics
Angela oh yeah he's a crazy assassin and
the kids are like oh cool snake guys you
know yeah but in the comics no no like
kids sounds like that there was a lot of
mystery and intrigue surrounding the
Winter Soldier like from the time like I
think it was about halfway through no it
was at the beginning of the comic but it
was at the beginning of a captain yeah
of the Winter Soldier run that we really
started hearing about the Winter Soldier
I mean we didn't know anything about him
like we knew nothing about him Nick Fury
is like well he's only appeared like
five or six times and I don't even
really have any information on this guy
and if Nick Fury doesn't know about and
then nobody knows about him right so
it's just kind of like alright I mean
who is this guy like you know what in
the heck's going on here and then
suddenly you know we've got in a panel
and the comic where Bucky Barnes has a
sniper rifle aiming at Captain America's
head so you know it was it was a really
cool like slow build-up and that's one
of the reasons why i loved-ed Brubaker's
run so much is because it was the slow
build-up you know we're sharing quarters
like I think it's Bucky and then it's
like BAM a full panel of Bucky Barnes
and the comic books the first time we
see him in almost like 40 or 50 years
and so it's a really really cool deal
you know and and I just felt like the
feeb men do but they couldn't do it well
they couldn't unless you had a film crew
out in the 1940s involving [ __ ] party
together in America I understand the
realization that he started in to assess
and it's not gonna have that same impact
yeah but in the movie it was like okay
you know like there's this plot going on
and there's something going on with
Hydra and we're not really sure what it
is and then BAM Winter Soldier and
that's kind of how it happened in the
comics honestly it was a build up in the
comics it was a you've got months and
months of buildup in a comic book and
you have an hour to have movie okay it
could have been a study you could have
seen
hidden hand you could have seen any
number of things I mean you know like
like we saw where somebody had
assassinated the Red Skull and then
stole the cosmic cube turned out to be
Bucky Barnes but we didn't know that we
just knew that there was somebody who
was going around killing people on
behalf of a Russian general who was
defected from the Russian government
like we didn't know what in the world
was going but you could do that an hour
and a half this D marble won't do that I
understand there were a lot of elements
from the comic they couldn't include but
they could definitely build the
character up over the movie but you
gotta think about it this way though
they're they're setting him up to be a
hero and you can't make him outright
kill everybody go insane in a
kid-friendly moving that's true cuz
what's gonna happen is this we're gonna
have that guy become the new Captain
America or get his own movie cuz he's
signed on for freaking nine movies he's
doing something else and you know little
Davey's mom is not gonna take a little
Davie to go see a movie where he just
met her why my little Davy all of a
sudden keep dropping out Davey's mom is
not gonna take him to go watch Winter
Soldier be a here over five movies and
then go pick up a movie where it builds
up how many people he's killed
okay you got to think about the future
everything's here that's true cuz if
they're gonna hide if they're gonna turn
him into a super hero not a villain he
needs to pretty much be a super hero day
one and the biggest thing that little
Davey's mom wants to see his two best
friends fighting that's it that's it was
Captain America versus Winter Soldier
that was basically yet I mean yeah yeah
so little Davey why is your mom so
strict I don't know my mom will buy me a
modem either one thing I will say in my
defense though is I think it might have
something to do with with a storm that
happened yesterday which also prevented
me from recording part of my show
because there's a big storm lots of rain
we've got roof damage that's fine and it
pretty much knocked down all of the
trees that were broken up in a windstorm
like two months ago as well so you got a
roof damage
yeah our roof is leaking in the next
room over like right now like I'm just
I'm looking like right up there at the
top of your bookcase waiting flight the
roof to come crashing oh no not not in
here you know my family has a guest room
over that way Oh every call we get into
it every podcast we do I've always
wondered this what is the mannequin doll
on top of that dress that is such a good
question that's alright it's something
that we used to while artists used to
use for like poses and sketches right so
they would draw that outline after they
posed like a the figure in that pose oh
and then they put the details over it
okay so better question you never put
that in a dress and dancing around do
you oh all the time best response
response okay okay so here's something
I've been wondering about with with the
introduction because we're gonna we're
gonna take a shot actually hold on real
quick to close it out real quick though
cuz we did start that I'm deep into the
bottle we the same thing applies to
demon in a bottle we've got Iron Man one
great superhero movie Iron Man three
great superhero movie he's gonna show up
as a primary carriage in Avengers one
two and three he's gonna pop up all over
the place little Davey's mom does not
want to take him to see Iron Man in all
these movies and little Davy loves Iron
Man so she goes oh let me grab this Iron
Man 2 movie and watch Tony Stark get
drunk the whole movie yeah okay I agree
100 Disney would most likely not condone
a film that in any way more or less
promotes alcohol is right well it may
not even Marvel when Iron Man 2 came out
I don't think that it was during that
period it was right at the same time oh
she makes me wonder though it's maybe
Marvel didn't even want to do it because
when you look at the future of this
franchise
yes we get to Iron Man 10 they're not
gonna make it rubber 8 at our movie -
exactly I can pick a weight in our movie
and we're not gonna get the Iron Man 10
where he's this amazing hero and then oh
look we had just had this one movie
where he gets drunk the whole movie yeah
I mean they're they're kind of dancing
like around I mean they're not even good
dance around the border we're like it's
the worst pg-13 movie that could come
out because they want parents that look
at you know their kids watching PG and
maybe they're starting to get old enough
to watch pg-13 movies that they can take
them to it's like here's the problem
Earth's Mightiest hero has Iron Man
Captain America and the Avengers in the
cartoon on Disney XD and that channel is
aimed for 10 to 12 year olds that's what
the whole channel is aimed for and
Disney even and even prop made probably
a lot of Marvel too because they were
selling these rights to Disney to do
this before that watch shoot it once
that 10 to 12 year old kid to watch that
cartoon and then see the commercial for
his favorite superhero and go see that
movie and if the movie is a giant
alcohol thing or winter sort of killing
dozens of people the little baby's mom
gonna be like what were they thinking
yeah yeah I understand where they're
coming from I can I can get that because
even even in conservative areas like if
somebody gets killed in a movie yeah
like a barn gonna go see it even look at
the TV show Marvel agents of shield that
skates around all death and crazy
mutilation and stuff like that yeah you
know they skate around all that stuff
because they're trying to keep that
family friendly tone across the board
because it's the largest demographic I
mean for example like like one of the
things that I'll be that I'm talking
about here in the next I don't know a
few days or so of the next week or so is
the tie-ins for civil war between two
and three and one of the tie-ins
is in civil war front line issue number
three I think and there's a fight
between thunderclap and Bantam I think
and thundercloud throws bantam into a
tanker truck and it blows up and so you
see like this this like sins varies like
you know there's this screwed up sinners
version of Banton like totally fried you
know and and that's not slow and you
probably see in the movie in I don't
know if I'm ruining anything I hope not
but when giant man gets killed
yeah you just he gets like a hole right
through his chest
it was probably ruined stuff don't tell
him who did it don't tell him who killed
him yeah yeah
your brutal this is actually a really
good question hobbies are a huge thing
right now right Oh God if they didn't
care about the rating guarantee we'd
have a Marvel Zombies movie I would love
to see how Marvel's not because there's
there's oh boy you can't make that for
kids I mean the topic is no way you
could do that as a family-friendly movie
you really couldn't I mean I care does
the brain spilling out of their heads
walking yeah well an Iron Man got cut in
half and he was like still crawling
around and his own intestines yeah it's
it's really you're just you're just not
gonna see that movie made though there's
so many more important storylines that
they could do other than an answer they
mention or theirs if they want to crack
down on money that's what they would do
okay okay so so Dave you bring up other
storylines and I want a segue into into
a question that I've been wondering okay
so we see the Scarlet Witch oh my god
you're obsessed with her magic our
little witch like really screwed up yeah
the actresses playing the scarlet
witch's is gorgeous like ever what her
name is but she's really good-looking
all right do you think we could see like
a House of M movie or and if I chose to
sell movie I wouldn't see an Avenger I
know Betty you're doing Avengers
disassembled on your channel I want to
see an Avengers disassembled like event
coming out of the Mars are you talking
are you talking about on the Fox side
around the Marvel side that's where your
problems gonna be exactly that's what
the problem is House of M and Avengers
disassembled incorporates a lot of x-men
and Avengers I feel like we're Marvel is
going right now with their franchise at
least their terrestrial earth-based
movies is civil war yeah well they're
gonna go anywhere and that comes way
after house of M
well here's what I see happening and
this is what I've been reading this is a
reason why we're getting a giant
Inhumans push
they're going to be bringing out the
Inhumans I don't know if even I don't
have to go to the store because Rob you
you get yours new digital mostly right
mm-hm okay and Dave you get big trade so
you're not really stayed up with the
current promotions going at store this
look I'm reading right now yeah there's
a big rush for the
vx companion okay yeah I'm sorry better
go ahead whiz a big push for the
Inhumans right now we have the inhuman
inhumanity event and didn't be brought
them into the forefront and there's a
large discussion of look if Fox isn't
gonna give us back the x-men then we're
gonna bring out the Inhumans and the
Inhumans are just a retelling of the
x-men for the most part they really are
how they got their powers and everything
everyone gets the powers due to the
terrigenesis
so there's a big theory right now that
phase 3 is gonna focus on the Inhumans
coming into play because that gives
Marvel that gives Marvel basically
mutants and they can reinvent every
superhero the same reason why we're
doing guardians the galaxy doing in to
know them because Marvel can't get back
spider-man so the theories of what's
going on with phase 3 is that we're
gonna get an Indian human storyline a
nova storyline guardians of the galaxy
is gonna get their sequel and then the
third event with fan o's is gonna be
incorporate all of them and think about
it Thanos Inhumans terrigenesis Bob now
you have mu in space that that's what I
was thinking man are they gonna bring
the terrigenesis bomb because the
terrigenesis Bob just scrapes throughout
the world and all of the Inhumans become
inhuman like they become they develop
powers and everything so right you can
have it in humans movie which is all
about Black Bolt and Medusa in there
that little in family war and then Fano
shows up looking for his daughter
you could you could if it it's set up to
be the Infinity Gauntlet right away they
could go for a infinity story and then
once you've got all of these new gifted
in humans all over the place and it
could do it could be in place right now
they could easily say that they're not
gifted that Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver are in humans and their
powers were awakened by Loki stuff but
other things what they weren't gonna be
in humans how easy would it be to
reverse that around son I'm saying but I
think that the it'd be kind of
disappointing to a lot of people too but
honestly to say they're inhuman later
than the say can you see me yeah it's
better it's better than saying like the
right it's like okay look I mean you're
crying hey there say they're inhuman
asleep right now we've never you seen
the Inhumans so if they just start
calling them Inhumans now you're gonna
be everybody who doesn't recom it's kind
of like what
but there's talks about a black ball
Medusa in human movie
coming out for Phase three and if we
have the Inhumans if we bring in a
Chilean and then Fano shows up boom goes
the terrigenesis bomb now you've got
whatever superpowers that the Marvel
wants to come out with if you bring in
Nova now you've got your teenaged kid
replacement for spider-man dealing with
his new power set cracking jokes and
they're just swapping everyone out
because that's what they have the rights
to stuff here's another question to you
also keep in mind that just because an
inhuman develops powers doesn't mean
they're gonna look the same like they
might go through like a physical
transformation so is Marvel really gonna
want to take the role of saying okay not
only do we have Inhumans and they have
powers but now we have people who are
like half-man half-horse and they're
super strong and now we have a man that
looks like a bug and he can run super
fast but I mean are they gonna go
through that whole thing you know or
they do I mean the court okay they can
easily get away from that the core
Inhumans that we're gonna know when they
come out because they're gonna go deep
even group gonna have black ball but
deuces none of them look crazy the
Inhumans group doesn't look crazy the
Inhumans themselves can look crazy
mm-hmm you know so we could very easily
just not do that this time around they
could easily rewrite all of that to make
it easier I don't know what do you think
Dave what do you think about Inhumans
well I think in terms of x-men in the
x-men movies I mean some of them look
really crazy think about toad yeah in
the x-men movies like he's got green
like slimy skin and old ontong and you
know his eyeballs are all like black or
like weird current toad version they're
doing from first class has all this like
melted looking skin with the big glasses
yeah I I think they could easily pull it
off and still have people watch the
movie and it'd be believable you know in
Brooklyn and they I mean they don't have
to feature the guy who's you know half
horse half human and strong they could
just have him off in the distance during
the the Terrigen mists and you know
basically just you know have him running
down the street or whatever freaking out
because
he's half horse you know it it could
easily just be thrown in there and in a
situation of chaos
I guess she's very quick I wanted to say
for anybody who's wondering who the
Inhumans are cuz they're not as popular
as a lot of stuff in marble yeah we'll
give I'll give a quick synapse as that
as our on the spot who are showing you
guys about tonight
so at the end of this yeah word oh and
actually even though I'm the Marvel guy
Benny can give you the rod if you want
no you do it then no I do every week you
doing what's your plan for something at
the end and we're talking about the
Inhumans like everyone knows who they
are yeah that's true so you explain who
they are at the end of us but to go in
the house of them one thing that we're
all some of them into yeah I mean but
you you go ahead assist you the bobble
guy no no talking about it Benny I would
I would just hate to step on your toes
when Quicksilver loses his powers in the
House of M he tries to get them back
with the terrigenesis crystals so a
couple of you've already got Quicksilver
messing with the crystals you could very
easily turn them both into just Inhumans
and make the Inhumans the new things
they'll be so easy to do and and this
but see also remember and during the son
of M storyline I mean you had you had
ramifications like he gave he exposed
Callisto to the Terrigen mists and the
center of powers an overdrive and so
like she had these just ridiculously
enhanced these senses that her mind shut
down and magneto had to take her away in
order to basically like you know keep
her brain from going going crazy but the
problem with the House of M is that it
is largely an x-men series like it's
triggered by the Scarlet Witch but it
follows Wolverine and this like it's a
great big huge event so you've got Luke
Cage from the Avengers from the New
Avengers and you've got Emma Frost from
the x-men a Cyclops and Layla Miller and
you've got Doctor Strange and it's this
really it's just such a huge and massive
crossover event Marvel really couldn't
pull it off by themselves which is why I
would love to see Marvel and Fox say
let's just make a really awesome
crossover event and base it on the House
of M that's what I thought about
Benny's theory or the theory that Benny
looked
is it kind of gives up on that
partnership if they're gonna do that be
in humans because there's no way to
bring the x-men in after they've made it
the Inhumans all you know all the your
girls doing you could easily say some of
these people that are mutants it would
take a couple lines but the reason why I
guess from what I've been reading in the
article Stanley is stating that they're
kind of done fighting to try and get X -
part of man back Fox and Sony are going
to do what they want to do and then
legally
Marvel can't get them back they can't
just take no they can't so Marvel's now
on an impasse did we wait until they get
bored of making movies or do we just
Marvel's got thousands of superheroes
yeah well if if they were to wait for
them to be bored of making movies - it
would be an all likelihood over for the
comic book movie in general yeah delete
except while yeah so they're just
convinced along with the newer stuff a
NASA and the Inhumans
they could easily incorporate into a
whole bunch of crap hey you could just
take the role of every one of the the
things but I as soon as you said how
some Emmet was thinking one thing Fox
could easily do that once they've gotten
a few extra movies under the belt we
fully established what mutants and
humans are they could easily do that
with me and they've already they've
already established their own Scarlet
Witch kind of exactly she's a little
girl but but that's that's the thing
because it's called a which is just I
mean she was screwed up by magneto and
she was screwed up my life experiences
and her her mind was just going crazy
because remember I mean you got the
whole Avengers disassembled event which
was like the lead-up to her going nuts
you know and then you've got the House
of M which is where she just falls off
the deep end so you know it's I would
really love to see a house of M movie
because one of the most did it what if
yeah what if their own house of them
with so Carla which is the as the
catalyst and Marvel introduces the
Inhumans makes Carla huachen and humid
and BAM now you have a house of Inhumans
I mean the Marvel version is gonna be
better hands down oh well but but be
funny knowing it I mean the entire I
mean the whole basis of like it's not
really like the whole pages but I mean
with the house of him like you've got a
lot of themes going on like you wonder
you got the Fantastic Four
or what was what was a fantastic force
so you've got Victor Von Doom who leads
what stands for what what passes were
the Fantastic Four and instead of Ben
Grimm playing the thing he's the it you
know so you've got like you know these
kind of replacements and everybody plays
totally different roles like apocalypse
one of the most premier villains in the
Marvel Universe is a subordinate of
magneto so you know I mean you've got
yeah yeah I mean you've got like all
these these total change ups from the
way that we see stuff Doctor Strange is
a psychiatrist you know I mean like
these are totally different and so the
way that it was done I hurts like
spider-man's changing the most where
he's a work when Stacy didn't die yeah
and he like is own villain yeah I mean
it's it's interesting because basically
it was a story where everybody got what
they wanted like it was a Scarlet Witch
giving everybody what they wanted more
or less she got her kids to him yeah she
got her kids and her kids have
reality-warping powers I think but I'm
like Hawkeye is brought back to life and
it was a really really cool event and so
I'd really love to see a movie where
that's done but the problem is because
it incorporates both the x-men and the
Avengers in equal levels because you
have x-men's x-men and Avengers that are
fighting together through Wolverine
because remember Wolverine is part of
the New Avengers and he's an x-man so
you know they're kind of fighting
through Wolverine or kind of being
brought together through Wolverine and
Lela Miller I would love to see a movie
based on that where the question is
would Marvel and Fox be willing to come
to an agreement and come together like
let's make this movie and then we'll
split never well fifty-fifty know both
properties regardless of who makes the
better movie both properties sell
millions they do so they're both gonna
want their half or what they want out of
it and they both think that they don't
need the other side yeah Marvel that
Barbra loved all be BeOS not be Fox
because they can easily go Inhumans boom
done yeah Fox has the entire x-men team
they can't make a thousand they can do
an x-force x-men x-factor X you know now
we're gonna do cable yeah the whole
debate of whether that they own Deadpool
what if they just want to Deadpool is
your god yeah so here a little bit we do
a quick run over on cable because the
way the Fox is doing him in the Days of
Future past is or in uh Xbox I think is
gonna suck but what are they doing
Brooklyn so there's the ultimate version
of cable which was Wolverine
basically Oh No yes but usually they're
using the ultimate version of cable
walls Wolverine if you think about it a
lot of the the film versions of
characters are based off Ultimate
Universe that's why I want to see
another bundle of Wolverine I'm tired of
Wolverine yeah here's what I find funny
about this whole ultimate thing though
everyone hates the Ultimate Universe but
every movie character is basically the
Ultimate Universe version well the
reason the reason like say say you were
gonna go with the ultimate version of
Tony Stark Iron Man the biggest reason I
have not read The Ultimate Comics
version of Iron Man is because he wears
the most hideous suit in the entire
universe I said I don't mean the
Ultimate Universe I mean any any
universes like there were offers over oh
you're not even saying that ultimate
Cable is actually like like Wolverine he
is a future person real yeah it's a
literal sense I'm not like it's not like
cable with claws they're not gonna turn
Wolverine like James Jackman Wolverine
into cable are they they probably will
and all right finally says I'm done
here's a deal with Wolverine alright one
on my channel I will probably never do a
video about Wolverine because he's got
14,000 issues that he's appeared in and
he's been done to death I have no
interest well I can understand them
wanting to feature Hugh Jackman in the
movies because I mean Hugh Jackman is
popular he's the most popular x-man in
all of the movies but to turn him into
other characters and have him featured
and literally every storyline it would
be such a pain eventually for people to
go through exactly even people who watch
the movies that don't read the comics
are gonna be like I'm getting bored of
seeing Wolverine all the time here's
mark I have an actual problem
I'll cover my bench in comics Torian so
since Rob Lowe everyone coming over
anyway okay
I liked Wolverine I do badass guy claws
healing power
the problem with Wolverine is he's
boring as [ __ ] and he's very shortly
he's got no real origin he's a mutant
who got injected with metal he's got no
real plot
he doesn't really incorporate too well
into very many of the plots he's always
the bomb I'm gonna kill a bub that's
that's the extent of his character
that's exactly it man that's what we use
in civil war he's like he's not joking
ventures vs. x-men he was like I gotta
go kill hope that was it Betty spent
like 20 issues like a probe yeah like
well I think the the most interesting
I've ever seen of him and he any
storyline I read or the storylines where
he's the teacher at the school
yeah you see more emotion out of it like
there's a scene in in the AVX companion
I have with which is Wolverine and the
x-men
you know the chunk of it that's
Wolverine and the x-men where he goes
out and there's a new student at the
school and he's talking to her by the
the Jean Grey statue and you know he's
he's like trying to calm her down and
you know be really super friendly and in
more gentle verses I was gonna go kill
people and drink beer I'm actually was
really glad you brought up that series
cuz that series has the most development
I've ever really seen at a Wolverine
cuz he's finally growing up beyond oh
I'm gonna kill Oh Bob I'm gonna kill him
yeah you know going in trancing through
mah swamps trying to find out what other
experiment was done to him seems to give
you that you're a new experiment has
been done to Wolverine we get it
revealed I actually followed that series
for quite a while I actually eventually
banded it though because I didn't like
the artwork on it I just I try I was
like in the story but I couldn't get
into the arms I love the artwork on that
did you what's going on it wasn't enough
pop on the foreground a background I
would just be everything on the panel
and I mean it was no Messiah Complex
alright but it was good it was good art
like I am yeah but the Wolverine I
overall he's a fan favor because if you
don't know comics and you walk into a
store first off he's everywhere secondly
he's this really
burly awesome looking guy with claws and
you find out that he could heal through
anything and that that is the Wolverine
character there's nothing more to him
but if you don't know that much about
comics
that's a cool character I mean that was
in fact that was something that like
Tony Stark poked at during Civil War and
and it was it was Wolverine vol III
issue 43 or something like that but he's
like you know you can't go hunting
around for a nitro because you might
cause another Stanford Connecticut you
know and Wolverines like well he killed
60 kids so I'm gonna kill him and and
that's it like this like that's all
Wolverine motivate that's all he'd ever
wors cut down nitro exactly that's
always his monthly Avengers vs. x-men he
looks for home yeah vs. x-men yeah I
just got through the entire infinity and
I cannot think of if he showed up at all
infinity I don't think he well uh no I
think he showed up with Captain
America's Team cuz that was mostly him
and Captain Marvel and then you'd have
Hawkeye and Spider Woman and them like
that it on the on the planet was all
about the Illuminati I think he had a
tie-in but I don't think is any major
you know I I think at the end of a V X
he has more character development to or
at least he has some more inner conflict
because he couldn't kill Jean Mimi I
don't like once once he finds hope well
no you couldn't kill gene before Oh
which from what I've been reading oh
yeah he wanted to do it beforehand right
it's it yeah he wanted to kill gene
because he was you know he was you know
going to II promised her because if she
lost control of the Phoenix and the same
thing that I was talking about like
Chris Claremont like the Chris Claremont
were on when she was dark Phoenix and
the comics I really I really haven't
read that one but I've I've read in AVX
that he wasn't able to kill gene no he's
right like that cuz he mentions that he
wasn't able to read kill gene and that's
one thing he regrets he could have
stopped gene before she went crazy and
everything like that right um but the
problem with Wolverine is he reversed
the status quo too quickly he's gotten
over the years a little bit of
development but every time he starts to
gain any more real character it always
turns back into alright now we're gonna
launch a new Vereen book and in this one
he's gonna spend 12 issues tramping
through the swamp trying to find out who
could have possibly done this latest
experiment to him dude I'm not
and I got a little development from EBX
I picked up the I picked up the the
Wolverine book and he went to the swamp
found a new doctor who did more
experiments on him and then he got into
a big knock-down drag-out fight with the
guy and I'm like that's bull who dares
worrying about even an original sin he
doesn't have much development which is
disappointing like he's just kind of
there and he's always there as I'm over
Igbo well that's I mean that's that's
why I mean because like how would I do a
Marvel explained video on Wolfram well
Wolverine first appeared and an issue
with the Incredible Hulk and then some
stuff happened and then he was the
record I have that [ __ ] it's a good
issue yeah it's like this some stuff
happened and then like Weapon X and then
x-men and then a new Avengers and x-men
and then like current day thanks for
watching peace I mean it's not gonna be
I really have no desire of this cut now
I do someone over to my channel if you
don't want to if you wanna know the fact
that it's not aa barber looks like a
Hugh Jackman is a good Wolverine for all
intents and purposes the way that he's
done and the way that his characters
portrayed Hugh Jackman is a good wolf
ring but the problem is I'm tired of
Wolverine most comic fans are tired of
Wolverine because he's in everything
yeah he's in 14,000 comics yeah I mean
he's in he's in so many different comic
book even if you are a super fan of
Wolverine you're like oh god just go
away I mean because you want to continue
being a fan of Wolverine yeah we don't
want to see him overdone because then
you'll get bored yeah like anybody's
gonna get bored if if they see him
featured everywhere like Tony Stark's
whole rationale or I'm sorry I either
Captain America Tony Stark I'll remember
who but their whole rationale for adding
him to the New Avengers was like when
they had like the whole Bucky Barnes
thing like well you're willing to do
stuff that we're not willing to do okay
so he's willing to kill people like
that's that's the only reason you're
adding him to the New Avengers roster
it's because he's willing to kill people
okay I mean that's that's it Kage had an
underground contacts you know of course
you got Captain America Miss Marvel
wants to come back into the fold Carol
Danvers I mean you know okay the only
other person that's less useful or
as useless as Wolverine in terms of that
score is Jessica drew spider-girl drew
she serves she is incredible background
character ever everyone knows what she
is and they leave her to death all right
Jessica Lee your IDs and behind us
lineup should have been when they read
when they brought that back the New
Avengers lineup should have been Captain
America Iron Man the century and who was
the other person I was gonna say Miss
Marvel man what do you guys like the
century in the Marvel movies
oh come on Seymour love to see the
century I would love to see the century
and more woman because he's like from
what I've seen so far he's like the more
mature like Superman of the Marvel
Universe like he's so like buff and
super strong well he's also got a screw
that's convoluted backstory - yeah he's
like he's like schizophrenic isn't he
yeah to a degree like it's alright
alright what we're gonna do ladies and
gentlemen listen to this podcast is
we're gonna do a Marvel explained video
within this podcast about we're doing it
on the Inhumans well we'll do that -
yeah I've got I've got like half an hour
left
yeah okay so anyway alright okay Rob so
Robert Reynolds a century um is he's a
super convoluted character he has an
alter ego called the void which is the
opposite side of the century the century
is Rijn or Mille every day Robert
Reynolds good guy superhero kind of
person the void is when he just kind of
loses his mind it kind of goes crazy and
he thinks the void is a whole nother
like alter ego like a whole nother like
individual and person alright he
appeared sporadically in the Marvel
comics he comes back in the New Avengers
an issue number 7 called the century
it's like a four part series and over
the course of the four part series what
we see is that in the previous events of
breakout he used his powers to tear
carnage in half and save daredevil and a
bunch of other people in the
Rikers Island prison when all the
prisoners were escaping
from Mary comes back the New Avengers
find him and he says they have to leave
because the void is coming all right
over the course of the next three or
four comics what we learn is that his
mind was screwed up by mastermind and
some general I'll remember who it was
and his mind is kind of slowly unlocked
by Emma Frost and ultimately like he's
just like this character that's built up
to be this ridiculously overpowered
character the most impressive display of
his abilities is that he hid the world
from knowing that he was this century
like he wiped every like the world's
mind from knowing who this century was
and he took the entire concept of the
century and he put it in the mind of
some comic book artist and that artist
drew out comics of this century like
that was how he kept himself alive more
or less and in the Marvel Universe as a
whole but he's got the power of like a
million exploding Suns he was able to
fight the Incredible Hulk to a
standstill to the point that they both
reverted down to their to their human
forms Bruce Banner and Robert Reynolds
like his molecules move I think like an
instant ahead of the current timeline
which is why he's so so powerful he
drank some kind of serum or something
like that like he's a super powerful
character like his powers go way beyond
anything that Superman is probably
capable of but he is he's astronomically
powerful well if Hulk is able to beat
Superman no we're talking about a 4-time
a world war hulk like get this I just
had an idea so there was the end credits
scene right where we saw Quicksilver
delta and the crappy actors oh my gosh I
can't believe this I don't know I'm
sorry Dave stop for a second no sir yes
he was good and kick-ass that we saw him
in Godzilla and now he's nothing oh no
sir yeah it's not a bad actor did you
see him
I just think that wasn't the right part
for me sergeant
do you have anybody that's actually
disarmed Bob no all right I'll go okay
okay let's let's let Dave get back to
his to his time sorry for interrupting
you I said imagine if if that end
credits scene was featured in another
movie but the camera pans over and we
see a bunch of other like prison units
that are keeping a ton of the other
Inhumans that that you know they're
they're experimenting on and the sentry
is one of them and Adam warlocks one of
them and ton of other like super
powerful characters they couldn't make
that umbrella can human I'd be sick all
right keep us on time um I actually
think it's a great idea but I decayed
you out of warlock in century that's me
then I think didn't they come up with
other things you know but if they were
to reveal there's more Inhumans already
that would be cool like what is it okay
taking your idea what if they panned
over into the Black Bolt the Medusa and
we do OB Inhumans movie out of that I'd
be I'd be stopped you down with that
yeah recycle that but all right so the
keeper on tracked robbed Inhumans go all
right if you guys want to see a video
about the Inhumans it's already uploaded
onto my channel so okay so the Inhumans
were originally yeah they first appeared
in Fantastic Four they first encountered
them as it's kind of a confusing
circumstance Medusa is the wife of Black
Bolt she's the queen of the Inhumans she
went missing for a while she was
rediscovered and there was kind of this
great big scenario where the Inhumans
were looking for so on and so forth
bah-bah-bah
the origins of the Inhumans start with
the cream and the courier like this
spacefaring race that a result of the
scrolls and so on and so forth but the
Kree had come to come to the planet
earth because the earth planet earth is
like at this strategic location between
the Kree in the scroll which is the
whole point of the kree-skrull war and
ones up happening is they see the
Celestials kind of like seeding the
planet Earth with life and with I guess
with a mutant gene and they decide to do
some experimenting on their own so what
they do is they create this race called
the inhuman
at the time when normal humans were
cavemen the Inhumans were super advanced
in terms of technology but what what the
humans there I'm sorry what the Inhumans
undergo is a process called terrigenesis
where they exposed themselves to the
Terrigen mists and it's literally like
them walking into this great big huge
like tank looking thing and the doors
closed and they're exposed to the
Terrigen mists now what the Terrigen
mists do is they activate a latent genes
so bidding was right when he talked
about them being mutants like with
mutants they approached their you know
adolescence puberty than their mutant
gene activates for the most part and
then they kind of go crazy and so on and
so forth with the Inhumans is pretty
much the exact same way when the when
they're exposed to the Terrigen mists
this latent gene activates now what
happens when it activates depends
sometimes they look exactly the same
and nothing really happened sometimes
like Black Bolt they have powers that
are so extreme like it's quasi sonic
scream which can destroy planets so it
really depends on what happens with the
individual what what really goes on
there but the Inhumans are really kind
of an obscure group I mean they lived on
the blue part of the moon for a while
which has oxygen they really kind of
live in isolation and the whole basis
for blackbolt
is to keep them isolated from everybody
else they don't really want to have
anything to do for the most part with
what goes on in the world they want to
be left alone but they are basically
like like Benny said they're basically
kind of like mutants they are really
kind of a less less trumped-up version
of the x-men they're not nearly as
popular for the most part they're not
nearly as expansive well I guess maybe
they are now after the events of in
inhumanity but nonetheless you know
they're they're really kind of like a
scaled-down version of the x-men but
it'd be a great way for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe to bring the Inhumans
into the fold without actually tapping
into the whole element of mutant which I
think that'd be pretty cool I'd love to
see some Inhumans it's just a good a
good replacement but they got there's
that one real quick there's that one so
Dave Olivier goes he was saying I'm
thinking about what I said in in how how
Marvel would would introduce that scene
if they were gonna do the the leaked
script for for Avengers 2
what could be easy they break in there
and spin humans have already been freed
or they've been moved mmm
so then at the end of the whole thing we
pan back to Racine at the beginning of
the movie and they pan over to the left
nearly oh my god there was more yeah I
mean you show black but like you just
you just hear some guy I don't know if
some guy screams or whispers or
something and then just the entire
building blows apart I don't know
okay and now to keep us on track here
because we're running low on time gotta
go through the comments like we did last
week okay
so the overall comments you guys were
saying is that a lot of people are
saying that they're sorry if I took it
as a dick we didn't take it as a being a
dick everyone commenting about me
talking over people
oh that's what we were saying we
actually want that feedback so we can
fix this so no don't hate anybody you're
all great thank you so much for watching
this we love ya that guy actually
commented on my video and he said the
same thing and it was like I really I
just think you know he gets excited I do
if you really saw you get that excited
I'm like a six year old kid who just
discovered candy for the first talking
about awesome stuff with Marvel comic
like comic books in general like it's
exciting exactly there's also a lot of
comments here about everyone loving the
podcast like a lot a lot of comments
everyone loved it yeah so I want it I
don't know what you guys but I want to
say thank you guys for enjoying this as
much as you guys are uh uh this is
really fun to do and I'm really excited
that Rob invited me over here to do this
with them and we love doing it I know
Dave does yeah like what like we we love
making this as much as you guys love
watching it so yeah and we really do
appreciate the comments because when you
see people liking what you're creating
that just gives you a good warm feeling
inside and it forces Dave to jump out of
half the podcast know like your
followers that came over to my channel
like I haven't gotten any dislikes and
I've gotten a ton of constructive
comments uh you know on how to change
things up or what to do obviously some
of them are out of my scope at this
point but you know like I think take a
Cameron yeah Cameron like he asked me to
do
like an entire history on comics from
like the year 2000 forward and I'm like
I don't
Cameron makes a bad sometimes I don't
know if he was joking around or like
whatever happened in one of our comics
ever yeah look Cameron's camera is a
really cool guy he's a good guy yeah you
gotta introduce me care but if you're
watching this I want to meet you
y'all bro he's 1 introduce me to your
channel to your whole YouTube thing back
oh man yeah I'll make sure that you guys
made up all right so we have any more
comments oh yeah I'm going through I was
getting him I wanted to actually go
through it I don't want to cut him off
by saying thank you
Karl Jon batiste apparently really likes
me and I really do appreciate that thank
you
oh man here and he wants to see beetle
versus Iron Man um and we actually
discussed we were gonna do that today I
know a lot about Jamie rates but
apparently Rob doesn't know enough about
Iron Man to compete with that so oh I
know enough that Iron Man I don't know
anything about Blue Beetle do something
yeah I don't I don't know anything about
Blue Beetle either I've been wanting to
pick up some of the newer books that
have come out you see that Dave light
did he just gave us like this look of
disgust he was just like goal doesn't
mean yeah yeah well booboo Udall has
always been kind of shuffled off to the
background and the newer Blue Beetle has
only really showed up in Young Justice
then he got fan favorite from that they
made economic out of him so the newer
Blue Beetle the one that he's probably
referring to I don't think he's
referring to the old one the new Blue
Beetle is somebody that you probably
don't know who the hell is Booster Gold
girl quick quick comic story and
complete story for it and know your
universe
Brewster Gould is from the future and he
has a base number of powers but if from
like machinery and stuff like that but
he figured out that in the future
there's too many superheroes he can't
compete he can't be famous and he wants
to be a famous superhero so he goes back
in town to the 21st century to trying to
be the best superhero so he can go down
in the history books he was he was a big
part how I know about him is I played a
lot of DC Universe Online yeah he's
actually the announcer most of the time
in that game like he he kind of like
to summarizes the situation and does
like little like get to know your hero's
features in that we should play in a
rage tank anyway okay we keep going down
here to be our runnin low seizure cows
wishes there was a comic book store
around him one thing that I can
recommend because I used to do this back
when I was in North Carolina and I
didn't know there was one 20 minutes
away they they weren't in the listings
so I only found that my reign of chance
Midtown comics
you can have them ship your comics every
week that's what I used to do yeah and I
mean there's there's always like I do a
lot of my comic shopping online I do
like to support my local comic book
stores I don't have to read around me
now it's gotten pretty popular around
here but do you know there's always
cheap graphic novels in Amazon where
where I do some of the shopping because
if I did all my shopping at a comic book
store I would be broke play spend like
they charge top dollar man yeah well
they they charge retail prices which is
understandable yeah but there are Zach
vos says he loved the Man of Steel and
he wants to know if you're gonna hit
gambit any time soon
Rob oh damn it after Civil War we'll
probably end up doing him gambit and
Emma Frost a few other people
a few people commented that Ben that
daredevil wasn't Ben's fault if you
watched the uncut version apparently is
a lot better and I have not seen the
uncut version I haven't yeah um I really
do think that that Ben Affleck really
couldn't pull off the writing in that
movie in the direction like he just
could not compensate for that yeah he
really was a good actor I saw him being
you know trying to pull off the dark and
broody thing during the the scene in a
bar like at the very beginning of the
movie where where he goes to kill that
guy after the court case and that was a
really good scene and in what he had to
say was was pretty genuine off the table
pretty sure I could find if like a
dollar yeah you know you can get the
blu-ray on on Amazon for like five bucks
okay I'll grab expensive
and this one with and Andre or Andrea if
I said it wrong I'm really sorry
Beverly stating that a Terrence Howard
was offered peanuts to do Iron Man 2 and
they really wanted dawn to play the role
in the first place that's why there was
the switch Oh from Don cheat Lee to
Terrence Howard and this I'm just gonna
say Gregory Clawson we love your
enthusiasm there's a lot here on every
video every channel we love you I need
to bring him on the podcast we need to
bring him on here like Gregory is like
he's so awesome I love that guy at the
very bottom I'm gonna say he wants to
know if we can parental lock his
computer from eBay when he listens to
this and then he mentions that he found
the Deadpool 27 taco time-variant so for
the record I also have that Gregory
alright yeah we definitely to bring him
on here but um alright guys well we're
gonna go and bring this this podcast to
and then like I know even going on for a
while but uh well I do want to say one
thing everyone leave your comments um I
go through this on the most popular and
the newest ones I can't we can't hit
them all every podcast but we do
appreciate every comment you guys leave
we do read them we do very much all of
us rotate through looking at these and
so thank you so much for all let last
week what we did also is we we went over
we were doing on our Channel Benny what
are what are you putting up you're
you're on vacation now you're gonna
break a little bit of a break to deal
with your Steam sale stuff um yeah today
on Thursday there will be some videos
coming out there'll be a couple videos
coming out for the tie-ins for Civil War
Between issues number 2 and 3 and then
I'm gonna take a break for a week and
around so I'm gonna take a break the
week of July 3rd rather and play like
Steam games and play video games and so
on and so forth and then come back we
turn well in the meantime convenience
for you guys is is that I will be
covering for you hopefully with my
weekly video that's gonna be out
probably by the time this podcast gets
posted we didn't play if it isn't you
guys should probably kick me in the
pants because
would mean that something probably
catastrophic has happened yeah because I
should finish that up tomorrow as long
as the stunts sun shining and it's not
you know storming violently outside my
internet it's good it's actually because
I'm going to VidCon next week so if
you're in the California area in Anaheim
I'll be in that area for like the most
of the next week and what I find out
doing is I'm not putting out any big
story videos but I'll probably be
shoehorning some no you're no you're
universe videos out there like I'm doing
one of the gallant to council on a few
things like that but for the next two or
three weeks I'm gonna go to VidCon that
I'm gonna relax for VidCon and then I'll
get back into the swing of things
awesome
all right guys we're gonna go and bring
this podcast to an end and yeah so and
next week I'll be from Anaheim
California on my laptop recording this
awesome alright later I have it going
see you